Jason Tatum got a new tattoo and people
are confused including a particular
actor who was actually featured in the
tattoo but first let's break down what
we're even looking at right now at first
you'll see a bunch of movie characters
inside of a work if you turn your phone
to the side you'll see the word spells
out life but that's not what's confusing
people it's what's inside of the letters
inside of the letter L is Denzel
Washington as John Quincy Archibald and
John Q then you go to the letter i this
is part that has everyone talking it's
Will Smith from Hitch but it's not just
any scene from Hitch it's the scene
where he had an allergic reaction Will
Smith commented on our post saying I
need to know why this pick and then he
added Jason Tatum Jason responded saying
we will talk moving on inside of the f
is Wesley Snipes as Sydney Dean and
White Men Can't Jump and then Dash from
The Incredibles is inside of the E what
are your thoughts on Tatum's new ink